The Muslim world always seems to get
away with things that would otherwise
send shock waves around the world.
Consider on May 29, reports emerged that
the Egyptian state was preparing to
close down and seize the oldest
continuously running Christian monastery
in the world. I speak of the Greek
Orthodox Monastery of St. Catherine,
which was built on Mount Si by Emperor
Justinian I around 550 AD, making it
almost 1500 years old. According to a
report from Church Times, the Egyptian
court ruling could result in the
confiscation of the property and the
eviction of its monks. Purported plans
included transforming certain areas into
a museum. This is a wild move even for a
Muslim nation. As Adel Gindi, an
Egyptian historian and co-founder of the
human rights group Coptic Solidarity,
writes, quote, "According to the law of
Egypt, if someone occupies a desert plot
and cultivates and develops it for a
certain period, 15 years, they are
legally entitled to own it and thus have
the right to sell it, pass it on, etc.
The state cannot simply come years later
and tell them on a whim that they were
merely beneficiaries of the land and
then seize it or force them to pay a
ransom. So what about this monastery
which has been continuously inhabited,
developed and cultivated for more than
1450 years? What indeed the monastery to
put this in perspective is older than
Islam itself. Christian monks have been
living in it since before Muhammad was
born. As such St. Catherine's is not
just some monastery or church that
Muslim Egypt is appropriating for its
own uses as it has done to thousands of
churches over the centuries. It is a
UNESCO protected site which by
definition means that the UN recognizes
it for having outstanding universal
value to humanity. It is therefore
protected under international
conventions to ensure its preservation
for future generations. These are all
quotes and language from the UNESCO
website. In other words, the world,
mankind in general, owns St. Cathine's,
not the modern nation state that the
monastery happens to find itself in due
to the vicissitudes of history, namely
the Muslim conquest of Egypt. In a May
29th statement, Eranimos, the Archbishop
of Athens and all Greece, condemned the
quote scandalous decision involving the
violent violation of human and
specifically religious freedoms by the
Egyptian judicial system, adding that
quote, "The Egyptian government has
effectively chosen to dismantle every
notion of justice and with a single
stroke attempt to erase the very
existence of the monastery, abolishing
its religious, spiritual, and cultural
function. The monastery's property is
being seized and expropriated. After
calling on the international community
to act, the archbishop closed by
writing, quote, I do not want to believe
I cannot believe that today Hellenism
and Orthodoxy are experiencing yet
another historical
fall. Yet another historical fall today.
While many failed to understand this
reference, he was clearly alluding to
the fact that May 29, when news of this
court ruling surfaced and when the
archbishop issued his statement, is the
very same date that Muslims conquered
another ancient Greek Orthodox church
also built by Justinian the Haga Sophia
in Constantinople, another UNESCO
heritage site that was only recently
violated by its Muslim overseers. In
2022, the Turkish government transformed
it into yet another mosque, even though
Istanbul has already over 3,000 mosques.
In other words, the archbishop's warning
that the Egyptian court ruling aims to
quote erase the very existence of the
monastery, abolishing its religious,
spiritual, and cultural function is
precisely what Islam has always done and
continues to do, despite trying to be
and trying to enjoy the benefits of
being a standing member of the world
community. as with Turkey, which really
wants to be a member of the European
Union. Indeed, to show you the sheer
hypocrisy, if not stupidity, of Egypt,
this latest court ruling blatantly
disregarding UNESCO resolutions comes at
the very same time that Egypt is
fervently campaigning for an Egyptian
candidate to be the next director
general of UNESCO. Look it up. His name
is Khaled
Alini. All right, let's take a step back
to underscore what Muslim nations like
Egypt and Turkey are doing. that is
spitting in the eye of the world,
especially its Christians. It's always
best to consider how this would look if
the shoe were on the other foot, if the
West did something like this to Islam.
Of course, one cannot come up with any
examples of Christians seizing mosques
on land that was always Muslim. It's
quite the opposite. Almost all of the
land that now constitutes the so-called
Muslim world was taken by conquest and
bloodshed, jihad, and mostly from
Christians all throughout North Africa,
the Middle East, and Asia Minor, but
also from Persians, Hindus, and peoples
further east. Even during the Crusades
in the Reconista in Spain, when
Christians transformed a few mosques
into churches, they did so knowing full
well that such mosques were once
churches. A notable example occurred
during the seventh crusade after King
Louis the 9inth put the Muslims of Egypt
to flight following the June 6th battle
of Damiata in 1249. That city's massive
mosque, once a church, was reconsecrated
as a church and Louie gave thanks to God
for his victory in it. In the words of
Louis's mother,
Blanch, quote, "The site of the mosque,
which some time ago, when the city was
previously captured, she means by
Muslims in the 7th century, was the
church of the blessed Virgin Mary. It
was reconciled and thanks were given
there to God most
high." Nor were the crusaders, unlike
their modern descendants, oblivious to
the fact that all of the near east and
north Africa and not just Jerusalem,
were originally part of Christendom.
Thus, Louis foundation charter for the
reconsecration of this same church
turned mosque turned church again dated
November 1249 says things like quote
after this country Egypt is liberated
from the hands of the infidels and quote
when this land is
liberated. At any rate, the point here
is that one cannot find identical
examples of Christians doing to Muslims
what Muslims have done and continue to
do. that is sees the pre-existing
buildings and sites of other religions.
And the reason for that is because Islam
is some 600 years newer than
Christianity and as such it is the one
that seized Christian buildings, sites
and entire nations, not vice versa. The
same incidentally goes for Islam visav
all other civilizations and religions.
Because Islam was the new kid on the
block, so too was it the one that
conquered and appropriated the sites and
temples of other religions, Jews,
Persians, Hindus, Buddhists at all, not
the other way around. As for those very
few Muslim buildings that were built
under Muslim rule, but have reverted to
Christian rule, such as in Spain, which
Muslims invaded in the 8th century,
destroying or transforming churches into
mosques as usual. These are treated with
immense care by Western authorities.
Take the Alhhamra which Muslims built in
Granada in the 14th century. Although
it's only about 780 years old, that is
half as old as St. Catherine's
Monastery. And although it was built on
what was then conquered Christian land,
it is one of the most thoroughly managed
UNESCO World Heritage sites in Europe.
And Spain spends tens of millions every
single year on it, euros, 28 million
euros in just 2022 to preserve and
maintain it. In other words, to
underscore what Egypt is doing, we have
to resort to our imaginations. Imagine
for a moment that there was an ancient
Native American temple in North America,
one that preceded European settlement by
centuries, one that is, of course, a
UNESCO site, and one that thousands of
modern-day Native Americans pilgrimage
to annually. And now, imagine the
American government announcing that it
is going to seize it and kick out its
indigenous inhabitants and turn it into
one more American church. How do you
think the world media, the loudmouth
left and international wokery would
react? No such reaction was of course
evident concerning Egypt's recent ruling
against St. Katherine. That said, Greece
did get very vocal enough to embarrass
Egypt and cause its president Cece to
issue a statement announcing his quote
full commitment to preserving the unique
and sacred religious status of St.
Catherine's monastery and preventing its
violation. That sounds good. But the
very next sentence states that quote the
presidency of Egypt affirms that the
recent court ruling consolidates the
status. In other words, Cece is not
reversing the court ruling. Rather, that
initial court ruling is, according to
him, dedicated to preserving the unique
and sacred religious status of St.
Catherine's Monastery. Huh? If that was
the case, why did the recent court
ruling provoke such a fierce response
from Greece and its hierarchs? CeCe
probably just doesn't want to admit to
any wrongdoing. It's all a
misunderstanding. He's trying to imply
the law itself is fine. The ruling is
fine. The Greeks just fail to understand
it. In reality, Egypt has been bullying
and threatening St. Catherine's for
years. In fact, back in 2018, I wrote an
article on how Egyptian authorities shut
down the monastery right before and
apparently to prevent Christmas worship
services. Link in the description. And
that's just the government. Arab
marauders, bedawinds, and terrorists of
every stripe have been known to target
the ancient Christian site situated as
it is in the Sinai Peninsula. As Adel
Gindi, author of A Sword Over the Nile,
a book that traces the plight of Egypt's
indigenous Christians under Islamic rule
from the 7th century to the present,
writes, quote, "This historic monastery,
St. Katherine, and its monks have
suffered greatly through the ages. Yet
it has never faced such an existential
threat. Not under the Umiads, the
Abbassads, the Aubids, the Fatimids, the
Mamluks, the Ottomans, the Muhammad Ali
dynasty, or even the post 1952 July
officers regime all the way through to
2012. Isn't it astonishing that the
current Neowan, he means neo
brotherhood, Muslim Brotherhood,
Egyptian regime is now engaging in such
deeply concerning actions? Indeed, it's
also a reminder that peaceful and subtle
Islamic minations, which the West has a
complete blind spot for, are sometimes
more dangerous and decisive than
run-of-the-mill Muslim violence.